Es ist schalte.
Ja, ganz schön.
Zum Beispiel.
Ich habe noch mal noch einen.
Vielleicht kommen die ganz blauen nicht mehr.
Das ist auch möglich.
Umheugen und wieder flatt.
Ja, umheugen und wieder flatt.
Der Roman weiß es.
Weil ich jeden einiges.
So einfach mal fortfahren.
Wie ist hier?
Gut.
Also ich habe noch mal Winti aufgerufen.
Aufgerufen.
Umheugen und wieder flatt.
Ich hab da Winti schon mal aufgerufen.
Und zwar ist es durch einen Gramm.
Weil mit dem ist es dann doch.
Und es gibt.
Und sieht da, wann bzw.
in welche Sinne.
Vermutlich.
Wolken.
So Hansen sind.
Auch da habe ich wieder das eigene D2 gewählt.
Wenn man da.
Wenn man?
Für Sonntagsraum möchte.
Dann empfiehlt sich.
Europäische.
Oder das größere.
Eiken mit 13 Kilometer.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und mit das in den morgen Tag.
Und man hält sehr hohe Seite.
Egen mit auf jeden Fall.
Und dann.
Und und und und wieder flacken.
Und.
Nete Maripolo.
morgens im Tag ziemlich ähnlich aus. Allerdings haben wir jetzt mit dem später noch Niederschlag
voraus. Also hier ab 7 Uhr, gleich die Nudenschlag, eher als die Bewölkung, aber das
ist nicht so die Bewölkung mit den restlichen Nennerien noch 10. Und auch mit der
Bewölkung, hier und trotzdem noch unter. Das ist so die Bewölkung auch 8,5 Uhr mit
deutlichem Nudenschlag. Das ist man hier eigentlich auch, da, in dem sich ein Kleft
zu sehen. In den Untergründen ist das gleich grauer, aber man sieht das dann mit dem Träben
ist. Das ist so sehr gut, das ist so. Und jetzt ist es aus meiner Sicht ein bisschen unmissig,
aber man sieht schon deutlich, dass dann eine Bewölkung tränen ist, ab 11 Uhr, das ist
zum Beispiel der Krab schon in den Wolken tränen, das sieht man da gut an dem fraffierten.
Also die Berg gibt es den klar größten Teil in den Wolken tränen, von ab 11 Uhr, wenn
wir dann auch mit dem Uhr war der Niederschlag, dem generell im Prokortiziert, die noch mal
mit dem Uhr, ein bisschen raus, da zeigt er jetzt bei uns noch nicht richtig Niederschlag
an, möglichst weiter kommt, da muss auch eine Bewölkung aus, aber die Gewölkung
mit den Niedern sind da noch nicht ganz vorhanden, man sieht es dann schon deutlich aus.
Also 8 Uhr in der Rede ist dann, sind sich eigentlich alle einig, dass da dann die erste Niederschlag
reinkommt. Wenn man dann noch hier rein steht beim Pissenshaus, da kann man dann die Bewölkung
da anschauen, die Zeit auch, was meine ich, nicht ganz so übersichtig gemeld, wenn man jetzt
mal nur diese Bewölkung anschauen sieht das dem Uhr in drei Uhr, ein bisschen anders aus,
da kann man dann nochmal ein bisschen eher sehen, man muss jetzt wissen, wo man sind,
und es war da, bei diesem kleinen Knick. Und kann man auf den Einen Region schon ein bisschen
mehr ausmachen, da unten mit der Zeit akte, dann ein bisschen weiter nach hinten sieht,
wo man sieht die Bisse, die Gewölkung da wie in den Gipfen, an den Gipfen, wir sind
heute der Tag. Aber sehr dünnlich, was das angeht, das Bisse, das Nied durchweits,
ich habe es da, also das Ert aufmeldet, wenn die Stolters mit der Gratten und sehr gut
übersichtlich und glücklich gewinnt. Mich sagt, man muss dann halt reiner Region schauen,
wie oft es hingekommt, es ist bei den Wolken von Nosen, und mal sehr, sehr gut passend,
und mal wieder aussehen, wenn ich, jaher, ist das so ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu betrachten,
also gerade im Ausland bin ich sehr schlecht gefahren hier in der Schweiz,
passt das häufiger gut, aber im Ausland ist es jetzt nicht so häufig so gut gewesen,
dass sie sagen ist, ja, da kann man sehr oft brauchen. In Niederschlag kann man da eigentlich auch mit
hin, in Niederschlag vom Arbeiten, dann auch noch die Möglichkeit dabei, mit der Schweiz,
zwei weitere Übersichtskarten zu fehlen, in die Welt von Norden, in der Variante,
man kann dann noch ein bisschen reingekommen, und dann in der Zeitakt,
wir da noch nach vorne gehen, es geht mir ziemlich nicht alt weit, aber wir gehen mal da um.
Jetzt sehen wir verholen Sie sich im Uhr, das sieht man, dass die größere,
größere Anteile noch weiter wechseln, und wir sehen mal, ob ich da acht,
bin in zwei, acht, zehn, nein und so, wo ich die sagen jetzt, acht,
ich finde es ist bei uns noch ein bisschen, ja, das ist doch laugend,
aber da, und ich denke, man ist nicht direkt bei uns,
das kann ich nicht mehr oder später, ganz genau, würde ich da nicht drauf gehen,
aber, und so sieht man sich alle einig, das am späsen Abend dann,
das ist der Niederschlag, reingekommen, und das am Vormittag bis am späten Nachtbetag,
und ich denke, noch der Niederschlag, er bleibt da und ganz schön,
ja, da, uns noch das ganz ein bisschen vom Fleisch sind,
immer danach hier oder hier, das ist bereit hier und hier ein gewährstgegen spät,
dann auch und dann, wenn der Fön schon richtig zusammenbricht,
die Front da reinkommt, dass dann dann wieder Schnau beginnt.
So kann man sich dann gleich relativ gut vorbereiten,
mit dem zu, noch, dass er Ektis App nehmen, wo,
eben, die, habe ich hier nicht oben gehabt,
nicht nur die Prognose wie hier,
soll die wohl, müssen nur die vorherberechnete,
eigemeine Lage, wenn das dann gut,
hier, und herberechnet, die gemeine Lage,
sondern daneben auch, ist die Sonntung,
die Link dazu, um 30.000,
die ich euch reingetan mit dem kommt und dann auf
in der Analyse, ein bisschen nach vorne gehen und sauen,
was da verhandelt ist und wenn man das ist,
das ist der Morgen ansauen,
das ist der Morgen, das ist der Morgen,
das ist der Morgen,
das ist für euch ein bisschen,
wenn man das Radikal von gewonnen macht,
dann haben wir dann noch ein bisschen weiter vorher weggehen,
wenn die 8.000 Stunden,
dann sieht man das da, die von über uns hinweg geht.
Also dann das Tag, nachmittags Abend,
und das Tag mit dem rechts,
mit dem rechtlichen Prognosen,
und so kann man eigentlich recht gut herausließen,
ist es für den Morgen-Motag,
dann in speziellen Dingen genau,
und gut ist es auch klar für morgen mit dem Start,
und dann sind wir jetzt 3.000 Stunden,
für einen Unpark,
wenn wir mal bei 20.000 Stunden,
das ist einfach ein bisschen weiter weg,
und das Unpark könnte man ja mal schauen,
was wir nicht machen.
Das ist keinem Training,
aber einfach das Interesse-Heib rum,
und da die Prognosen aussehen,
oder wir sind auf europäischer Gedanken.
So, wir haben es doch noch mit der Manag.
Wir finden den Wind aus 3.000 m herz.
Und wir sehen,
dass da 8.000 Prozent kein Mahner ausgemeldet ist,
man hat es jetzt nicht unbedingt,
der Roter Lichtpunkt in sein, hier ohne ordentlichen Kärk jetzt.
Auf zwei oder drei Metern wird das wirklich weniger sein, aber die Frage ist halt trotzdem
jeder von Ausgrafvertrag trotzdem, vielleicht sogar 15 km, haben nur Nord-Leans-Fraben- und
Starbplatz.
Und jetzt das Seinscham vom Staaten hier, muss man es wissen.
Da, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Mitte-Fan-Apo-Sundag ist mit Drennen und da und da und da und da und da und da und da Fing auch wieder ein bisschen des Films, vielleicht
wo die Stärke hier aus sich, wenn wir mal in Karm haben und die Tat auf der Nebenlieben, aber ja, immer noch vielleicht 30 km aus,
noch ein Meter nur durch, schlecht der Ristung, also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass das am Drennen-Dach auch noch nicht so viel verbrechend aussieht,
dass wir dann eher weitet haben, noch mal so ein bisschen den Kanker am Drennen-Dach, dann kann man es ja ansteigt, dann kann man es weiter aus dem D.E.
Ja, starker Wind, wir sind noch viel, dass wir die gleiche Zwei- und heizt auf uns ab.
Das letzte bei mir jetzt da ist noch nicht so gut, aber vermutlich wird eben genau das Eintreten verbreiten.
Einten.
Einten, doch können Sie mir jetzt auch vorstellen, dass das bei uns eher der Fall ist.
Drei Einten, das können Sie in Karm auf der Hinsen, nicht von Hinsen.
Also, als Schätzleger liegt mit allein dann in den Reinen verglichen, ausgeglichen.
Da haben wir noch einen gezahlen, dass das Eintag eher viel regiert haben.
Der Wind auf 2.000 Meter, da bin ich ein bisschen hochbiet.
Ich bin dann immer fast nicht mehr so ein Winter.
Und das ist jetzt in der Vergangenheit nicht so gut gestrungen.
Und wo ich eigentlich die Drehvergänse im Moment immer frei, und hier bei Börner noch cool, die 2.000 Meter.
Und jeder von uns, dass das in etwa hinkommt, das 3.000 Meter.
Das wird vermutlich angeblich ankommt.
Und dann wird zwar schwierig allein von sich gaten.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Sonne.
Sieg mir doch mal wenn es dann geht, dass das da auch noch mal ein bisschen besser kommuniziert.
Also, vor dem her, jetzt rein zu dem Grundsack vermutlich vom Windherdelementierengefaktor,
wenn wir auf die Vorhersage, Bodenfunkarte von Deutschen, die Wetterdienste,
dann haben wir unseren Tag.
Das ist die Bundeswetter-Biedenlage.
Das geht anhand von den Inselbaden hier.
Der Begründer vom Inselbadenlage.
Wenn Windgruppen uns jetzt noch mal definitiv ist natürlich nicht immer so.
Aber wenn wir gerade in der Barren langgehen, dann nehmen wir doch mal da eher unstandardos Wind haben.
Und das ist beziehungsweise mit diesen Begründern 3.000 Meter.
Das ist auch nicht so.
Und wenn es grundsätzlich denke ich vor der Bewölkung her am guter Tag sein,
dann muss man natürlich bei Dienste immer den Hochnebel in Betrachtung ziehen.
Und klar kann man eben hier bei der Ausfall der Diagramme noch auf dem Hochnebel geben.
Und wann, was der durch in der Obergrenze hat und der mit am Sonntag von 17.000-1800 Meter gehen,
das ist sehr hoch.
Das ist vermutlich so einen Park, wo der Hochnebel sogar bis zu uns hinterzieht, hintergedrückt wird,
mit der starken Biese.
Könnte das jetzt für den Sonntag auch bei uns,
wenn man sehr in die Tieren da fahrt nur sein, also kann sein.
Das ist über 1.800 Meter.
Es ist sehr sonnigiert und wird hinterher hängt man dann im Hochnebel fest.
Ich denke, wenn man sich so ein bisschen vorzubereiten mit den verschiedenen Apps schafft,
dann auch vergleicht, das ist immer ganz wichtig am Tag selber.
Wie war die Prognosen, hat sie gestimmt.
Ich habe 7.000 haben gemacht, das gewisse einfach gerne zu viel anzeigen, zu viel,
weil sie zu viel Wind angegeben oder auch eher auf der pessimistischen Seite sind.
Aber schließlich ist es ja für ein Flieger besser als wenn zu gut gerechnet, zu positiv geregnet wird,
zu optimistisch gedacht wird, dann klar steht
im Motiv.
Es gibt eine linke.
Und in den Menschen, in den Menschen zu korrecten sind.
Es gibt immer auch auch auch auch in der Mengen.
als Tipp mitnehmen und mit Metropanonismus sehr, sehr gut. Wir haben in Eibaranien mal
zu reinget aneinigt, dass es jetzt noch mal so hittend ist, vorhanden sein wird, wenn die,
ich habe noch andere Karten angeschaut, die das prognostiziert haben. Börner hat auch in
Eibaranien komplette Gewürkung acht, acht lang gezeigt. Nur Metropanon hat uns eine
Wolken Basis angegeben, 2.000 Meter, 2.000 Meter und schlussendlich haben wir fast gar keine
Wolke gehabt. Also da müsste man wirklich schauen, was ist für euch, an dem Ort das
besser ermitteln und dann vielleicht halt mit zwei, maximum drei Apps arbeiten. Ich
stell euch noch den, gut zu un
ich glaube, dass das man beispielsweise im Ausland viele Informationen, die snarzt
in der lande Plätze, oder auch einen in den Szenen noch erhält.
In dich war der Darstellung her schon wahnsinnig gut, in die ich nix aufs Wort.
Mit einem Blick und den Trai, dass es hier Informationen heraumt gibt.
Ich war am Anfang kein Fan, davon bin aber mittlerweile schon überzeugt, dass das auch eine gute Sache ist.
Man brummt die Oda, die mögliche in der Landung mit dem Rutschen
über das normalen Achtung und Mekte oder auch einen speziellen Norweifwagen hat, der kann mit mir direkt anschreiten.
Wenn er jetzt nicht ganz sicher sein, woran er noch mal ein bisschen in Formationen nachbuchen könnte,
lieber das einzelne App, könnte er mir eben schreiben.
Oder das Ganze dann später auf der Humpage unter dem Errektivbereich nochmal nachschauen,
da werde ich die Präsentation hochladen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, es war so von meiner Seite noch Fragen, das wäre eigentlich noch ganz cool,
falls jemand Fragen hat, oder ist etwas unklar gewesen, zu schnell gewesen, zu wenig im Vorgeweben.
Du bist da das jetzt gerne schreiben oder handheben oder gerade Mikrofon an und die Fragen stehen.
Du hast du eine Frage, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, du fragst uns vor mir, du hast du beim deutschen Wetterdienst jetzt die potenziellen Hochnet-Lobelgrinzen,
wo hast du das gefunden?
Also, also das schicke ich euch den Link.
Das ist super, perfekt.
Wunderbar.
Weil das ist noch gut zum Speikern.
Jetzt, wenn du mal hochwertabfunk erhältst, sind einfach Daten vom Deutem Wetterdienst.
Gut, noch andere Fragen, auch, auch solche Sachen, natürlich willkommen, und dann noch etwas unklar
ist.
Okay, dann werden wir sagen, als eure Aufgabe ganz klar morgen schauen, wie wir jetzt die
großen
und die Progrosen gestimmt, wo wir da heute angeschaut haben, ist das eingetroffen mit dem Slag am Abend zwischen 18, 19, 20 Uhr.
Das ist etwas, was er morgen abgleichen müsste, vielleicht einmal schauen, da unsere Station geht jetzt nicht,
aber die Kraftmaßende Institution auf 200.000 Meter DG, da könnte auch nutzen, was ist da für einen Wind.
Das sind 2,500 Meter, dann kommt das schon, wenn das so um die 20 bis 30 KMH Wind ist, dann ist auch die Progrosen gut
auch immer getreten, hat da eigentlich auch gut gestimmt.
Also, das ist das, was wir morgen mal machen können und das empfehle ich euch auch für die Zukunft,
auch vielleicht für Tage, wo nicht fliegbar sind, was einfach schaut, was habt ihr für eine Prognose gemacht und was es tatsächlich
eingetreten? Weil ich nur so könnte euch verbessern und lernen und merken hier, das ist sehr gut,
das ist nicht blugut gewesen.
en. Für unsere Region ist eine Sache, wo ich festgestellt habe, da haben viele noch mehr Teobluhe,
aber dann hat jetzt bei uns in unserer Region, was nicht, also darum müsste da eure eigene Erfahr
und heute, ja, ihr.
Erfahrungen sammeln. Das ist wichtig. Danke vielmal für die Nizit.
Danke auch. Schönen Abend noch.
Danke. Danke.
Amen on. Tschüss.
Ciao. Ciao.